all right these are C-SPAN calls
garai next up is ranol Illinois good
morning good morning guys how you doing
um first I would just like to say that
you know thank you to the bat right
there for just with all the persecution
and all the stuff that's been going on
and you guys have not been getting a lot
of fan service as far as things go and I
just really want to thank you for
sticking through it and keep doing your
job and you know keep doing what you do
um despite you know a lot of uh people
really not liking it and as far as that
goes I would really just like to give
you a nice big mle Virginia you're
on
the
well well I do
[Laughter]
declare this morning for jug Greg go
ahead well hello Governor Greg first I'd
like to say that you were my governor
and congressman and senator for some
time and we were calling for you to run
for president yourself but your
supportive M Romney M Romney as well and
of course the uh Mitt Romney has very
high expectations uh for the campaign
and for his victory in the New Hampshire
primary I was running what size lead do
you think he needs to avoid a
disappointment and also how big is M
Ron's
penis Charlotte North apologies Governor
Charlotte North
Carolina apologies sorry he would have
no idea how big Mitt Romney's penis is
this is sepan for God's
sakes Glenn called in from Salt Lake
City Utah Glenn good
morning hi good morning my question is
since we're we we're spending all this
money where are we getting the money
from and my second question is if I can
in your mouth I'm apologize for that
Congressman don't take that kind of
language here on the Washington Journal
uh we'll move on I like how it's about
the an it's about the language not the
action itself it's more I can I poop in
your mouth oh well sir would you be able
to poop in your mouth with cpan you can
answer that question where does the
money come from nobody knows that's what
I thought we were going to get an answer
on but alas not
today